I'm really happy to be here with you I'm
gonna talk I'm going to talk about the
Last Judgement hopefully I can make it
cheerful
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
the reason why I wanted to talk about
the Last Judgement is because first of
all it's one of my favorite icons and
it's one of my favorite icons because
just like the Last Judgement or just
like the end just like the the that
moment where everything comes together
at the end the icon of the Last
Judgement is actually an amazing
synthesis of all of iconography and in
the icon of the Last Judgement we find
all elements you'll see as we kind of
move through you we find elements and
structures which are in all our icons
but brought together into this one kind
of gigantic icon moment and so it's a
it's it's a good way to kind of
understand also what iconography is
working towards one of the things that's
important to understand is that the
early church and even today the church
even the building of the church the way
that it was conceived is based on the
Last Judgement so the early churches
even if you go to Rome and you see some
of the early churches you'll see that
what's represented is this
eschatological moment right so for those
who don't know as eschatology is this
coming this coming of the last thing
this coming return of Christ but also
that moment where everything is going to
become clear and everything will be
revealed in its totality and so the
church was made that way the the early
Christians things were it's a bit it was
a bit complicated the way they were set
up it's a bit different from now but
they would the the the Christ that we
see here in the Dome of the church is
the returning Christ it is Christ who is
returning and so to understand the icon
of the Last Judgement is also to
understand the the kind of the total
visual tradition that the church has
given us as much the the sacred space as
the way that the image
have been laid out in the sacred space
because it's not it's nothing is
arbitrary okay and so we're going to
look at the icon of live judgment I'm
kind of just kind of work through it and
I'm going to try to help you see how
it's connected to the other icons and
hopefully how it ultimately connects to
our own life and to that it is actually
not just an image of this cosmic moment
of finality but it also shows us the
very process by which we attain to that
moment the very process by which we can
enter into the resurrection all right
so haha the way that the icon is built
you have to see it kind of in two ways
you see it from the top to the bottom so
there's a vertical reading of the icon
and then there's left to right okay
so if you look at it you can see that I
chose this one particularly because it's
very clear there's like a line that goes
straight down the middle of the icon
which separates it from with the left
hand and the right hand of Christ okay
and then there's also different tiers of
the icon which represent that this
vertical reading okay
so the first element we need to look at
of course is the central element the one
that pulls our eye in that kind of
brings us the first thing that we notice
as we look at it is of course Christ
who's there at the top of the icon and
who is represented as this returning
Christ the Christ in glory and like I
said this image of Christ is also the
image of Christ in the Dome of the
church its Christ in glory who is
returning in that final moment but it's
not just how can I say this it's also
Christ in every icon that is the way
that Christ is represented in our
iconography the fact that he's red if
you look at Christ
he's not a hundred percent but in so
many icons he's represented wearing this
this vestment which is the aroma
investment of a senator so a vestment of
a high-ranking person you know
ultimately it becomes this notion that
that Christ is like the king crisis like
the Emperor Christ is this high figure
and so that's how we represent Christ in
the icon because Christ obviously in the
first century did not go around Galilee
wearing a clevis which is this the sign
of Roman nobility you know with a with a
very fancy Roman dress that's not how
Christ physically dressed obviously not
but the reason why we represent Christ
that way is because we're always looking
towards that eschatological moment we're
always trying to show what all of this
is leading us to and what it's leading
us to is this moment where everything
will become clear and Christ will return
in glory and so if you look at the
images that you have even in your parish
you know if you see Christ raising
Lazarus or if you see him at the
resurrection you'll notice that he's
always dressed as had he's always
presented as this glorious Christ okay
and so Christ is sitting on a rainbow
and he he is returning you can see the
same image right there if you look at it
over here
it's the same way that he's represented
at the Ascension and the reason for that
is technically it's because that they
said the angel said you know just like
he went up you know that the same way
he's going to return but it also helps
us to understand that in the icon of the
Last Judgement this image of the
Ascension is also brought into this
image it's brought into it and the way
that the Ascension is represented shows
these two these two tears and so we have
Christ who's ascending as the head of
the church and then under we have the
church itself which is represented first
of all as the mother of God in the
center and then the Apostles that are on
the side and so you have these two tears
you have the head you have the body and
so the Ascension that image it could
almost be the return of Christ because
that's also how Christ returns you dis
he's he's going to come back and and and
manifest the unity of the head and the
body the total unity of the head and the
body alright and so next to Christ is
the Theotokos the mother of God on his
right and then Saint John the Baptist on
his left then to the continuing on that
side you have Saint Peter who is on the
right of the mother of God you have st.
Paul who's on the Left of Saint John the
Baptist
that's what we called Babli okay the
Babli is the basic pattern of all once
again of all of iconography Christ in
the center flanked by different Saints
in a sort of hierarchy usually the
mother of God to his right st. John the
Baptist to his left you see that often
you'll see it in an icon of Stathis for
example okay so in the iconostasis it's
not it's not a hundred it doesn't have
to be a hundred percent this way but
often in your iconostasis you have that
as well to the right of Christ is his
mother but then often in the Econo
status will have to his left there will
be there will be Saint John the Baptist
okay and why do we why do we why do we
have those two right why do we have
those two because those two are the ones
who pointed to Christ they're the ones
who said this one right
his mother by by burying him and Saint
John the Baptist as also that's also
coming before him but there's more than
that there's more than that okay and
already we're going to start to see this
other separation of the icon between the
right hand and the left hand okay and so
of course we know when we when we have
the right hand and the left hand we we
think immediately of the parable of of
Christ and the sheep and the goat so
this is actually one of the earliest
images of the Last Judgement hey this is
a sixth century image from from Ravana
and here it's very simple right there's
Christ in the center and then there are
the Sheep to his right and the goats to
his left and there's Saint Michael on
his right and Gabriel to his left okay
go back here and this is going to it's
going to be the first sign to help us
understand that this is really a cosmic
image because we're we tend to think of
the right hand of Christ as good and the
left hand of Christ as bad but it's not
necessarily so right there is there are
there are positive aspects to the left
hand of Christ as well and we see those
in Saint John the Baptist in Saint in
Saint John the forerunner we see the
what I would call the positive aspect of
the left hand okay and so quite what
does Christ say to the sheep and the
goats he says to the sheep and the goats
said so the sheep come right come in
come come into the kingdom and he says
to the goats move away move away now
that is what we see the mother of God is
everything that is the right hand in the
positive aspect of the right hand she is
covered right she is brought she is she
is she's a she's hidden right she's
inside she is she is an image of this
bringing in and that's what she did to
Christ she got
third humanity in her womb so that it
could receive God you know in her womb
and so that is this gathering and the
mother of God is almost always has this
all this whole notion of gathering and
we even in our own interaction with her
that is how we see her as this mother
that gathers in okay and then the Saint
John the forerunner he is the wild man
and so he is that he's the very opposite
she is closed hidden she she is
completely covered and he's wild and his
hair is crazy and he's he's wearing
sheep skins and you know he's living out
into the desert and he's screaming to
everybody
repent repent repent and the mother of
God she's in the secret she's in silent
and and and and we encounter her in that
silence and in that secret okay and so
we already have this right hand and left
hand but it like I said it doesn't it's
not necessarily negative and then if we
move just a little bit further we see
st. Peter on the right of Christ okay
st. Peter who's that foundation who's
that rock okay the imagery of st. Peter
is that that image of the of the
foundation right he's the apostle to the
Jews so he's this this rock and the
apostle to those that are the inside
those teach those that are on the inside
and who's on the other side right it's
the Apostle Paul who's the Apostle Paul
first of all he was a strangely a Roman
a Roman citizen and he was the apostle
to the Gentiles he's the kind of
somewhat legitimate you know apostle the
13th apostle he you know he he comes on
the fly he you know and and then he goes
out to the world and he preaches to
everybody okay so you have this image of
this moving out but this image the
moving out is a positive image at the
beginning right it's not all it's all
it's not just a positive and negative in
terms of morality it's really it's
really a cosmic structure it's this it's
the structure of reality this is what
we're looking at okay it's the way that
the world works okay and so now let's
follow the central
one of the reasons okay so the reason
why Christ is sitting on a rainbow is
because he is sitting the heavens
there's a a text in the song where it
says that God is sitting on that the the
heavens are his throne and the earth is
his footstool and so here is Christ
showing us that he is divine and then
sitting on the heavens and the rainbow
is obviously a symbol of heaven because
it is that dome right it's that arch
that we can see but it's also a bridge
right it's also this bridge which
connects heaven and earth and so we get
all of that in this image of Christ
sitting on the rainbow it's a very
ancient ancient image all right so as we
move now down the line we have an image
which is called the Hettie Messiah okay
can you see it it's that that weird
square right here okay so that weird
Square with the cross and the two angels
that's it's called the head - Messiah
and what it is it's the prepared throne
it's the throne that is prepared for the
return of Christ
now you could you have it like I said
you could take that image of the
ascension and it's the same thing right
so we don't show in this this we don't
show the mother of God there but we show
a throne and the mother of God is is
Christ's throne it's another vision of
the church which is preparing itself
which is laying itself I was preparing
itself to receive its King its King so
the church is is is that's what the the
notion of the empty the empty seat
represents it's a very ancient image and
it's very interesting because it
actually can help us understand a little
bit of how the church some of the the
difficulties that were present present
at the beginning of the church because
the the idea of the head to Messiah was
present started
at the end I seek the Nicene counsel at
the Nicene counsel when Constantine
couldn't be there they left this throne
which was empty and this empty throne
represented the power of the the Emperor
in his absence and a lot of the fathers
were not so so keen on that they kind of
you know they they weren't so keen on on
having that type of imagery and so right
away at Constantinople at the next
council right away they did the same
thing but instead they put a book of the
gospel on the throne and so it became
rather than being an image of an empty
seat prepared for the emperor in his
absence
it became an empty seat prepared for
Christ in his absence and there are many
people there are many many scholars
until now who believe that that throne
the the the bishops throne that used to
be in the apse of the church at the end
of the of the apse of the church was at
first a throne that was left empty
because it was the throne that was
prepared for the return of Christ the
whole liturgy was based on this idea
that we were waiting for the returning
Christ and the throne is here prepared
so that Christ can sit in his throne
right but it's moat but it most
importantly for us it's really to
understand what the church what's the
role of the church's right what it is
that we have to do even in our own lives
the idea of preparing the throne I mean
that's that's what we need to do in
ourselves we need to prepare ourselves
we need to work on laying laying things
out properly preparing the the body into
which Christ is joined to okay and so
that's that's our work and it follows
down in the in the middle of the of the
and then of course there is there's the
cross that is there on the the throne
and the cross acts as this balance
there's a I don't know if you have this
riparian but there's that riparian in
the Russian tradition which says your
cross or Christ is like a balance right
for the thief on the the
who looked at you was raised off and the
thief that that didn't was cast down so
the cross already is an image of the
Last Judgement in the cross itself is
already this everything is accomplished
in the cross so we have this balance
this central axis which goes down which
separates the left and the right hand
side and that's what the cross acts as
that has that image then we have the two
angels and the two angels it's very
fascinating I this part I don't totally
understand this part and I'll explain
why look at the two angels the red and
the blue angel so this is really this is
this is a sixth-century image okay and
the red angel is on the right hand of
Christ you think it's st. Michael and
then the blue angel is on the left hand
of Christ I don't totally understand it
and here they flipped it okay if you
look at an iconostasis often you will
have an image of Saint Michael on the
right hand side you have one but often
on the other side you'll have an image
of Saint Gabriel doesn't have to be an
image of of Gabriel but it often it will
be an image of Gabriel but so that
structure like I told you that basic
basic structure has been there from the
beginning it's just that you see that
sometimes the two angels seem to to to
flip on each side but this very this
this kind of cosmic structure is there
and the way the iconostasis lay it is
laid out it's there the way with with
the dome everything is totally coherent
in the way that it's set up and so now
moving down from the the de Mesilla then
we have the angel which is holding the
scales and so the scale itself like the
cross right it's this straight line
which goes down and depending on what
side which way things are going to go
and it's represented as this angel on
the right side and the demon on the left
side this
everybody has seen this image before
this this image it's it you see it in
you know when you were young you saw
these cartoons and there was a angel on
the right shoulder and the devil on the
left shoulder right that's that right
there it's the same thing the same image
okay
it is this possibility that we have
right that we have in ourselves saint
gregory of nyssa it goes as far as
saying that god has appointed for each
person an angel which encourages us
towards towards heaven and a Corrupter
which which tempts us and brings us down
okay
and so decide this is a very ancient
tradition this idea of that that there
are these two sides Homer Simpson didn't
make it up like it really is this very
very ancient idea of this these two
possibilities within us right these
these two possibilities of either giving
in to our passions to that which divides
us that's what pulls us apart
and it brings us down or else giving in
to soup we're not giving him sadly we
wish it would be that simple but
submitting ourselves to the higher
virtues to love to charity you know to
compassion and then being able to to
move up and so the in this image this is
the judgment itself and so the soul is
being judged of the person it's being
judged whether it has it has been pulled
down whether it has gone up and you see
this I think I have an image of it right
so here's a good image of it so here you
see the soul sometimes in the image of
the live judgement you'll actually see
the soul which is standing in the middle
right as this person who could go either
way like we can go either way and then
the angel that is putting in the in the
scroll the the the good things that the
person is done and then the demons that
are trying to pull the scales down so
that you go that way and in this image
it's the hand of God who is holding the
the scale and in his hand are the the
souls that are that are there to be
judged this okay and so and it's not
just an image of the Last Judgement this
notion this is the image of our life
it's the image of our daily life this is
an image of the divine laddered and what
it represents it represents the
struggles of the person in their life to
ascend the ladder to go up and encounter
God to to reach the state of
illumination and unity with God and in
that image it is it is at the same time
this image of a judgment or this the
same image that you saw with the angel
on one side you can see right here
here's the angel and in this version the
angel is holding a crown sometimes you
have the angel just encouraging the
person to go up and then on the other
side you have this demons that are that
have these hooks trying to pull the
people down into the mouth of death
that's down there into the mouth of Hell
so that's really you know if you can
leave with just one thing today is to
understand how the limit the image of
the last judgment and the last judgment
itself is something which is already
happening now it is not just something
to wait for it is it is the very process
of our of our existence which will in
the end before will be fulfilled in in
the last judgment but is already part of
our of our existence today yes climbing
the ladder now yes definitely definitely
I mean the st. john climacus wrote a
book called this bit is based on the
book by it's by st. john climacus which
is the ladder of divine ascent and a lot
of people during lent they read this
book it's very hard to read
don't-don't-don't probably don't read at
least don't read it without the guide of
a spiritual father because it's really
written for aesthetics but
the principle of the book or the
principle of this notion that we are
called to ascend that we are called to
encounter God and be united with God
fully totally you know as much as it's
possible as same accident says that
that's that's what we're called to do
right and so the the the process of the
resurrection is one that's happening now
and you read it in the Saints you read
it in in the father's that that we can
already participate in the resurrection
now and when we when we take a sacrament
when you take the Holy Sacrament we are
already in that eschatological moment
that's probably one of the hardest
things to understand when we take the
sacrament when we taught when we sing
and we talk about that we are united
with the cherubim United with the angels
gathered together right and then we
thank God for all we thank God for all
that he's done for all that Christ has
done and then we name them right we
heard it today
I don't know didn't heal it but the the
the Incarnation the the death the
resurrection the ascension and then the
last coming we even say we thank you for
that which has already been accomplished
we are living we can't we have access to
that eschatological moment already now
one of the aspects that we see in terms
of the right and the left hand which
isn't in the first image that I showed
you but is often in the image of the
Last Judgement is we often have Adam and
Eve which are there next to the throne
of prepared judgment something not
necessarily always in the exact same
place so you have here Adam on the right
of Christ and then you have Eve on the
left of Christ right and so that also
brings in to the Last Judgement
the image of the Anastasis the image of
the resurrection so they were in the
image of the resurrection we have Christ
that goes down and brings up Adam and
Eve you know to there resurrect is very
mysterious to their resurrection and
here they are right Christ has brought
them they're here they are right now
you know part
paiting in the Last Judgement
participating in that moment standing in
for all of us standing in for man and
woman that as being the father and
mother of all of us okay so it's and
here in this image it's very it's it's
very interesting because you see Christ
on his left hand he's holding a sword
sometimes you'll have Christ with the
sword coming out of his mouth on the
Honda on his left side
depending in our image we have this
scale this balance where Christ is
raising up his right hand and lowering
his left hand and if you want to
understand what this means right here a
lot of people wonder why the third bar
of the Russian cross why is it tilted
why is it slanted right and that's
that's why because your cross with
Christ is a balance and there's that
same gesture in the cross that you have
Christ doing with his hands and it's
very you find it all over the place this
is a this is an image this is the
Florence mapped baptistry right this is
a Western this is a Western image based
on Eastern prototypes but here here you
have Christ raising up his right hand
and then pushing away with his left hand
and the same he's sitting on a rainbow
he has his mother on his right side
he has st. John the foreigner on his
left side there's st. Peter it's hard to
see now I don't know if that's st. Paul
- okay maybe it's st. Paul but this is
really I mean this is not just a this is
a very this is an image that had been
built up in the church from the very
beginning right from the very first
structure of how the churches is built
all right so now on the right side of
Christ we have the Saints right that are
like he said in the the
the image of the sheep and the goats the
Saints that are on his right side
getting ready to be gathered in to enter
into the kingdom to enter into his mercy
below that we have paradise
so paradise is down here and can you
tell what's going on here can someone
guess what's going on here No
so that is st. Peter what is he doing
what does st. Peter have in his hands he
has got the keys he's opening the door
he's opening the door to paradise and it
and it's and paradise is the Garden of
Eden people a lot of it's very a lot of
people struggle it they always think
that when we die we go to heaven that is
not a Christian understanding at all we
don't die and go to heaven
the return to the to paradise really is
that that that image of the New
Jerusalem at the end of time this
joining it's a joining of heaven and
earth it's a resurrection of the body
but it's not this dis incarnated
floating spirits right we we will have a
it's mysterious I don't know exactly
what it means but but there is a
resurrection of the body and so on the
door of paradise is the cherub that God
put on at at the gate of paradise to
stop Adam and Eve from entering into
paradise but is that the only place
where God put a cherub at the gate of
paradise where else is there a cherub at
the limit of something you know so on
the veil of the temple before entering
into the Holy of Holies
there were cherubs which were stitched
into the veil and so the cherub that's
at the gate of the garden is also the
chair of that is at the entering of the
Holy of Holies so to enter into paradise
is to enter into the Holy of Holies is
to enter into that sacred place
it's to to to to
to ascend the mountain with Moses to go
up to the holy place okay and so the
entering into paradise
is also entering into the holy place in
the church it is this this encounter
with the sacred okay and so we have
Saint Peter I don't know why st. Paul is
there but I think it's because st. Peter
and say Paul kind of always have to be
together you know it's like the apostle
to the Jews apostle to the Gentiles we
need the right in the left hand you know
and this idea of the right in the left
hand is there you know it's there in
separate is there everywhere I want to
show you an image of oh here I forgot to
show you this image this is an image of
the of the Council of Constantinople and
now you can see the Hetchy Messiah in
the back the prepared throne with the
book on it and then all around are the
Fathers of the Council and now the king
or the Emperor is sitting to the side
he's not sitting in the middle you know
and this prepared throne for Christ is
the central the central image but in the
image of Pentecost we have the same
structure they're the same structure we
have st. Peter on the right st. Paul on
the left and in the image of Pentecost
also we have the prepared throne right
see that's empty space between st. Peter
and st. Paul that space is prepared for
Christ and so it's the same it's the
same ideas the same concept the image
the image of this empty space between
the two is the same image as the hits
and messy it's it's the it's the
prepared throne for Christ as he returns
to join himself with his church
ultimately alright okay
now in Paradise who's in paradise can
you guess who the first person we
encounter in paradise is no what does he
got do you guys see he's here he's right
here
what is he carrying no he carrying
carrying a cross
who is who it's the Good Thief right
it's a good thief and it's important to
understand why we have the Good Thief
there because I told you that cross is
where all was finished where all was
accomplished on the cross and so the
good thief becomes the image becomes the
image of all those who look to Christ
and Christ says today you will be with
me in paradise
right and it's it's true it kid it's
true for everybody like today you can be
with me in paradise if you look to
Christ and so the good thief becomes
this first image of the this first image
of what is happening on the cross and
what is happening in the whole story of
salvation okay so that's why we have the
Good Thief there someone said what the
next one is with next one that's a weird
one if you look at it can everybody see
what's going on there no show you I'll
show you an easier one to to to
recognize wait oh yeah so this one I'll
tell you so here's here's that here's an
easier one to recognize of this although
of what what's happening there on the
right obviously I'm not on the left side
it's someone else it is
yeah it's Abraham and he has on his lap
Lazarus who said Lazarus someone said
Lazarus all right
because right because of the story that
Christ told about about those two places
about the right hand place and the left
hand place
one of them was represented as Lazarus
sitting in the bosom of Abraham right
and one of them was represented as
someone who was in the in the place of
suffering now in this version and in
many versions it's not just Lazarus but
you see all these heads these visual
heads in the CLA's claw right and it's
this gathering in of of Israel into the
bosom of Abraham now what's important to
understand is that these images that you
see all those images that are there but
they're there for a reason they're there
to help you understand what paradise is
what is that okay and so the bosom of
Abraham that's an image of what paradise
is it is this returning to your origin
going back into the the place out of
where you came from right going back to
the garden going back to Abraham those
are two images of the same thing they're
just in different levels but this idea
of going back into paradise into the
garden from which we came from which we
were dispersed then going back into
Abraham is the same thing right it's
just it's just that it's just slightly a
different a different version and that's
also why next to Abraham who's next
Abraham my hiding people right so it's
the mother of God so the Theotokos is
next to a bruh why for the same reason
right she is paradise okay so the mother
of God is paradise because she is the
place where creation met its creator she
is the place where heaven and earth
touched just like paradise was this
mountain where heaven and earth touched
and Adam and Eve were at the top so to
the mother of God is that place where
heaven and earth touched she is paradise
she's also the throne she's all those
image he's the church she's all those
those images of
we can come and encounter God and we can
receive God you know to the extent that
it's possible and that's why she she is
so those images that you see they're not
just arbitrary things you put in there
but they are all images to help you
understand what are we talking about
when we talk about paradise right what
are we talking about so it is it it's
the church I told you it's an entry into
the holy place it's it that's why we
have those cherubim paradise and the
church art are the same the mother of
God and the church is returning to our
origins that's returning to the guard
and all these images when to start to
lay them out and you start to to see
them next to each other it can start to
awaken father talk about talk to us
about the news and because we can't
access the news with our with our
rational thinking we can't access it but
these these types of images are there to
awaken in us you know to connect things
together and to awaken in us this this
intuition okay because obviously
paradise is not I'm gonna say this
but I mean all these images are there to
help us understand what what paradise is
you know and we we have to take them
together we can't just we can't just
separate them but I hope that I hope
this is this is important all right now
how we go to the to the bat's how we go
to the nasty side all right let's go to
the left side all right now on the left
side first thing you notice is this
crazy red river that flows out it flows
out of the foot of Christ and that is
that that comes from a vision in Daniel
in the Book of Daniel when the when
Daniel sees the Son of man coming he
described this river of fire which flows
from from from its throne you know and
and comes out let's not talk about that
for now let's talk about the top part
first so
I'm sure that this image right here that
is probably some of the weirdest images
you've ever seen what's going on up here
right here okay so what if you you it's
hard to see because the image is small
but what's happening is you have all
these beasts that are spitting up people
okay so you have all these different
monsters right see that guy coming out
of that sea monsters mouth there's a guy
coming out of the lion's mouth right so
all these monsters are spitting up
people and the same for the fish all
these six there's like what is that what
is that and then you have a angel who's
blowing a trumpet so what the angel is
blowing their trumpets saying you know
it's the angel of Revelation blowing the
trumpet to call the dead to rise and so
the ways we show this is by showing
these beasts that are giving up their
their prey why do we why we show it that
way because this is also I've been
trying to show you that this is not just
this is an image of what's going on in
you right now it's not just an image it
is an image of the total final image of
the cosmos but it's also an image of
what's happening in you right now
and so these beasts are the passions
they're that there are there are these
monsters there are all these things that
rip us apart that that tear us apart
that that bring us down into death and
here are these beasts that are giving up
so you see it's not just beats you see
people coming out of their tombs as well
right so some people coming out of their
tombs and then some people are coming
out of these of these different beasts
and so it's all it that's the image and
the Church Fathers of the animals of
this this kind of
maladie is always this image of the the
patient right the the when when Adam and
Eve fell God gave them these garments of
skins thanks and it was this joining it
was this joining to our animal nature
and so the the animals that are giving
up their dead is really an image first
of all of how this image of death that's
what it is it's an image of us being
devoured we all experience it everybody
has that experience of being pulled down
by your passions whether you know it
could be your you know whether it's
hunger whether it's it's your sexual
passions whether it's pride whether it's
you know avarice all these passions they
pull us into death okay and then but it
is also possible I mean it not only is
it possible but but it is in in the it
is possible for those to give up their
dead at the Rick at the calling Rite of
Christ and we can enter into and come
back from that that that that experience
okay so if there's it's it's it's very
interesting it's very important to
understand that those two are kind of
laid up against each other right here
and right here okay so here we have
people being eaten by this beast and
then above it we have people being given
out like being regurgitated like and
this is not arbitrary I know I know it's
some people might think it's arbitrary
but we have a very old image of this
very very old one it's this one it's not
this is there's reasons why these images
are chosen right because we know that
the resurrection has already been
represented as Jonah being spit out by
the fish that we're coming out of dead
death is coming out of this this Anam
animal existence it's kind
ray raising ourselves up you know and so
that's why not only that's why the
beasts are spitting up the people that's
also why the the head of the fish
becomes an image of right becomes an
image of Hell itself can you see that
it's the same so Jonah's the image of
Jonah's fish becomes this alt image of
the mouth of Hades the mouth of the
mouth of death in the West the image of
the anis ptosis of the resurrection this
is the Western image of the resurrection
okay and so in the East we have this
image here that you all see of Christ
raising Adam and Eve out of this pit and
out of the tombs but in the West it was
always Christ raising people out of this
mouth of death out of this mouth of
Hades okay
and it's and this image is there in the
east - I showed it to you before see
down there so there it is also in the
image of the ascent right also to remind
you that this is happening now
right this is not just I mean it is the
ultimate image but it's also one which
engages us today all right I'm almost
done
[Music]
yeah the possibility yeah well it has to
do I mean I think it it has to do with
this notion of the left hand as being
related to the wild to the animal it's
also the desert so you can see in the
image it's it's it's the wildness so
while listen in the Bible is represented
as the desert right when the the
Israelites are lost in the desert so you
see this desert but it's also the flood
right it's also the waters so you have
these two images together you have the
images of the desert the image of the
flood so it's this it really is this
image of the
limits right the different images of
chaos different images of of the limits
of what is ordered okay and so that's
why it's on the left it's on the left
hand side but like I told you the left
hand side is not just bad it just is it
just it's just it's just an aspect of
reality okay but there is obviously the
ultimate you know the final image of the
of the of the final judgement of those
who are eaten by the Beast and we know
that it's possible right I mean we know
that people can let themselves or fall
so so deep that they are devoured and
fire is really the best image image for
that okay but it's important to
understand that fire is not fire is not
just a bad thing it's not just a
negative thing it's it and there's we
have another fire right we have that
fire right there okay see they have fire
and so fire is this multiplication it's
this division it's moving out and so the
the fire of the holy spirit that made
people speak in languages that everybody
could understand right that's like st.
Paul that moves out so it's that left
hand that moves out but that also can be
fragmentation it could also be something
that you lose all cohesion and it's ash
the only thing left is ash okay
and so it's an image of this breakdown
well there it is slightly I I wouldn't
limit it to that I would say that the
right side is really this bringing in
and then the left side is this kind of
this breaking apart but you could you
could use those terms yeah it wouldn't
be totally it wouldn't be totally but
there is a there is a negative right
side - I'm not I'm not talking about it
here but there is also a negative aspect
of the right side as to do it has to do
with st. Peter st. Peter is the right
hand of Christ but he's the one who also
is full of pride right so pride is their
sin of the right hand st. Maximus the
Confessor said it explicitly that pride
is the pride in self you know self
sufficiency is this is the right hand
sinned and then the passions you know
drunkenness and prostitution all those
types of things there are sins of the
left hand there sins that dissipate but
in the image of judgment really then
finally this is the final the final
image and often in the good image is
that allowed judgment you'll see kind of
different categories of people that are
that are kind of in the fire and so
usually they'll be like here we see
there's a king often gonna be Kings
they'll be usually we put the Kings and
the bishops and the priests and we put
those that but yeah anyways especially
in the West that's what happened in the
West you really had this tradition of
showing of showing only you know kings
and and bishops and priests and monks in
hell and and normal people yeah they
don't go tell I don't know I was trying
to figure it out I couldn't I couldn't
find what was written but I think it it
probably has to it I would think that it
would be the words of Christ saying
enter into my kingdom on one side and
then you know ya depart for me I think
that's what it is but I couldn't I
couldn't read the I tried to read that I
couldn't that give you an idea of this
this icon yeah I mean I miss did I
answer your question or did I miss kind
of miss your question
yeah go ahead go ahead again bless
judgment and and some of the Assumption
there is that everything on the left so
it's it's fallen it's going to be
consumed it's it's the chaff that's
separated out but yet there seems to be
a promise a hope right the desert and
the flood led to renewal you have to the
resurrection from the tombs the the
redemption from the passions that
swallowed them so is there some seed of
Hope that's built into this and and why
I think no I think I think there
definitely is I mean there definitely is
and like Brust there definitely is a
seed of hope that that that which pulls
us on the left side or Allah that what
pulls us into fragmentation into death
we can be saved from that obviously but
I we have to be careful about we have to
be careful like down there like down
there I would say that that it's it that
all all abandon all hope you and you
know like Dante Dante put that quote up
there and I think that I think that that
what exactly that entails like we don't
know what exactly that entails but I
think that part of the Christian
tradition there is really this idea that
that that there really really is this
this possibility of losing yourself and
I think that that's important you know
and yeah I think it's important that it
is possible to totally lose yourself and
to that there is no way back but it you
know yeah so one final thing yeah so is
this is this you mentioned this a sort
of reflection of reality so is this
what's going on within us now this yeah
this tear but also the final thing that
definitely how I see it but I also see
also I also see that that last judgment
as the finality of all like of all of us
but we can like I said it's it's still
now it's that it's also now yeah and I
think that there's nothing this is
absolutely Orthodox to say that because
that's why our liturgy is the way it is
that's why in our liturgy we are already
in the kingdom that's why we are already
in the res
erection we are participating in the
resurrection when we when we take the
sacraments and so it really it's really
there it's part of our but obviously
it's mysterious because there really is
this also this notion that there is a
cosmic finality into into which
everything will be transparent yes
Father here we go
and I am I get in trouble for this I'm
telling you in some images of the Last
Judgement you will see a big snake so
you will see this giant snake which is
swerving down depends not always exactly
the same and this one he's biting the
heel of Adam and the snake is swerving
down down into the fire and along the
snake there are these nodes it's that's
exactly what it is it's exactly chutes
and ladders and on the snake just like
we saw on the ladder of divine ascent
there are angels right and the angels
are helping people up the snake and then
there are demons that are pulling people
down the snake so it's exactly chutes
and ladders and that let me see if I
have another image of this here's
another one alright so here we see it
more clearly because you can see the
angel the angel then the demons at each
node okay and those those nodes are what
people call the toll houses and the it's
very controversial in the Orthodox
Church and tell you right now I'm not
I'm not
not taking one side or the other but I
can explain to you what it is and the
total houses are this process or the
process of judgment of the person you
could say they're just like the latter
there are these different nodes and each
node represents a sin and a virtue and
then the the story is that the soul
sends these nodes and that each step is
there's an angel and a demon just like
all the others and and and if you pass
you go up and if you don't you stay
there right and so it is the the very
process of sanctification and so I think
also in the the toll house is it's
important to to understand also that
although we see it as happening after
death it's the same as the ladder it's
the same thing it's happening now right
it's it's it's also happening now and so
that's the this image of this this snake
but when you said chutes and ladders
it's like there's you couldn't have had
a better a better image
it's a chute and a ladder at the same
time the same thing role in the economy
of you know the role that were meant to
be tempted we can grow yeah this case
you overcome in order to fight
temptation unless we're sanctified you
know
let's see the graces we go up against
and we become and I think that's really
important to understand is that as as we
ascend as we as we ascend the ladder
then we become what it's at that ladder
it's not just a question of of arbitrary
judgment or arbitrary or like you did
this and you didn't do this it's it's to
become something
it's to acquire a virtue and so and as
you acquire virtue then you become that
which is at that level right and and and
you become more and more in the image of
God right so it's it's it's a process of
transformation of the person it's not
just a bunch of rules you have to follow
in order to go to heaven or to go to
hell it's that's not that's not it
it's to become something and what you
become that's paradise itself right to
acquire the virtue is paradise there's
nothing else right that's what it is
to become something and to enter the
paradise is to become that which is in
paradise is to be in the holy place to
have to be in a in a place in yourself
and in your in your life where you can
are transparent to God that you that God
flows through you and you have nothing
holding it back okay and I think that's
really important to to to understand one
last thing I want to show you about this
one sorry these ones is here you really
get when I told you about this right
hand and left hand and some of these
icons you get it like you know like like
it's it's almost like going up and going
like an elevator and I should you know
so on one side you have these saints
that are ascending on the right side
they're going up on the right side of
Christ then on the left side you have
all these demons that are falling down
into the fire so you have this ladder
right and all these nodes and then the
the ascension and the descent on the
other side right and so it's really it's
an imager like I told you it's an image
of reality it's an image of the the the
hierarchy of the world it's an image of
the the ontological hierarchy of reality
alright so I think I mean I think I've
kind of gone through the icon
there they are like there are variations
and I'm not going to go through all the
variations because really there are all
kinds of variations on this image that
kind of gave you a basic structure of
what this icon looks like and then you
can or you can then explore what you
know like in this image for example you
you have you don't have the the dead
people getting getting thrown up by
animals but you have the same images
here you have this grey mass and you
have all these people inside and you
have the angels that are calling with
trumpets and so it also is this Grey's
being raised up out of death that's
happening and here it's it's it's been
put into contrast directly with the
mother of God as an image of paradise so
you have these two sides you know
opposing each other if you enjoyed this
content and our exploration of symbolism
get involved I love to read your
comments in the comments section below
please go ahead and share this on social
media to all your friends and also
please consider supporting us
financially on patreon you'll find a
link to the patreon page in the
description below